brought to you by Bioshock the
collection have you ever wondered if
rapture the underwater city from
Bioshock could exist in real life
well I can tell you the answer but yes
for 25 billion dollars it totally can
in fact Japanese construction company
Shimizu Corp has conceptual plans for an
ocean spiral an underwater spiraling
city that can house up to 5,000 people
almost nine miles under the surface of
the ocean hopefully it'll be slightly
free but for this episode of reality
check brought to you by Bioshock the
collection I figured that underwater
cities had been done so I started doing
some blue sky thinking of my own
Bioshock Infinite's
Columbia was as much a main character as
Booker or Elizabeth but could this
majestic city in the clouds actually
exist
Columbia was built essentially as a way
for America to flip off the rest of the
world and show everyone just how great
its ideals were admittedly this
monumentally backfired on them when the
citizens of Columbia destroyed Beijing
seceded from the US government and then
floated away to rule itself obviously
Columbia would have had to have been
built on the ground and make its way up
to the sky somehow well we know that
Booker hitches a ride on a pilgrim
rocket to take him up the 15,000 feet or
so needed to reach Columbia but could a
rocket be enough to lift buildings all
the way up there noticed science editor
Kyle Hill had a crack at the maths it
turns out it's not that easy to find out
just how heavy a city is so he ran his
numbers using the weight of the Empire
State Building his reasoning is that if
a rocket can hold up a big building like
the Empire State it's plausible to
extrapolate those findings to create a
sky bound city the rocket in question is
the Saturn 5 used by NASA to support the
Apollo moon program back in the late 60s
and early 70s it remains the tallest
heaviest and most powerful rocket in
operation and holds records for the
heaviest payload launched three hundred
and ten thousand pounds but is it enough
to lift a building given that the Empire
State Building weighs three hundred and
sixty five thousand tons
Kyle calculated that 420 rockets would
be needed just to get the building
airborne the first stage of Saturn's
liftoff consumes 1.4 million pounds of
refined petroleum and 3.17 8 million
pounds of liquid oxygen for 420 rockets
that's this incredibly long number on
your screen right now
pounds worth of chemical weight that
doesn't sound sustainable or good for
the environment
OK ROCK except out so how's about
Columbia's other flotation device
balloon although I think we're gonna
need something a little more heavy-duty
helium floats because at sea level its
density is no point two kilograms per
cubic meter whereas the density of air
is 1.2 kilograms per cubic meter max
says a cubic meter of helium can lift
one kilogram of mass fill plant who
writes slates bad astronomy blog
crunched the numbers on how much helium
would be needed to raise the Empire
State Building
we know the Empire State weighs 365,000
tons which works out as 330 million
kilograms do the math and that 330
million cubic meters of helium Kyle Hill
noted that this is the same amount of
helium that could power 1650
Hindenburg's and Phil worked out that
you would need a balloon with the radius
of 430 meters to fix it all in bearing
in mind it's 443 meters from the ground
to the very tip of the Empire State
Building so that's a pretty pretty big
balloon so while technically possible
the best kind of possible this sounds
like another no-go I'm running out of
ideas here so let's try quantum physics
don't turn off it's genuinely quite
interesting a superconductor is a
material with two very important
properties number one it displays zero
electrical resistance which means that
electricity can flow through it with no
loss of current and number two
superconductor rejects magnetic fields
so if you place a superconductor on top
of a very strong magnetic track one or
two things will happen if it's a type 1
superconductor it rejects magnetic
fields completely but if you have a type
2 superconductor that has many small
defects which allow some of the magnetic
field to slip through however once the
magnetic field goes through the
superconductor it can't get out the
superconductor then gets locked in place
above the magnetic track
which is a phenomenon known as quantum
locking but crucially the superconductor
will only behave this way once it's
cooled past a critical temperature a
pretty chilly minus 196 degrees seemed
well I don't know about you but I'm
already foreseeing problems with making
a city float this way for starters the
land would have to be covered in super
super strong magnet and the city itself
would have to be constantly cooled by
liquid nitrogen making it completely
unlivable what killed the dinosaurs
there is it might be for the best that
we don't live among the clouds we know
from the game that Columbia is around
15,000 feet in the air which is
classified as very high altitude by
medical experts now we humans are a
pretty squishy species we're not really
made for high altitudes exposure can
lead to altitude sickness or even the
potentially fatal high-altitude cerebral
edema also it'll be cold as seeing as I
don't think we're gonna be living in the
clouds anytime soon it's a good job
we've still got the nice cold hard safe
ground huh anyway hope you enjoyed this
week's episode of reality check don't
forget i'm on twitter at lucy games
games for more videos like this one
would you kindly like and subscribe to
GameSpot's see you next time